hey I'm Pete Holmes here at the Glendale
fighting club
I'm here with Ronda Rousey rowdy Ronda
Rousey she is I'm gonna get this right
because I don't want you to hurt me the
mixed martial arts
undefeated Queen and the undisputed UFC
women's bantamweight champion holy cow
you're so lovely oh thank you yeah
the title doesn't really seem to portray
that yeah that's why I want to get it
out there you're beautiful but I know
you could hurt me like a butterfly with
a switchblade you're confusing what does
it feel like to break an arm do you feel
bad cuz if I broke an arm I'd be like
yeah I won but also like sorry no no
first time fight is trying to take away
everything that I've worked so hard my
entire life for why I feel bad for them
you're terrifying does it bother you
when people fixate on your looks
no I'm an entertainer now it's not like
the Olympics going back yeah it's the
Olympics it's not about looks but um you
know I tell me about it
you should I can't decide what
intimidates me more about you your good
looks or the fact that I know you could
pull off my balls like a paper cup
dispenser but don't worry I'm fine
unless I get paid these days I know
right I wouldn't be Jeff you should see
me off the show or off offstage I'm like
not funny at all yeah yeah that's why
you didn't talk to me at all before the
cameras went on you're like I'm so
brilliant but I only have so much and I
don't want to waste any of it while I'm
not being recorded so don't talk to me I
just got served
isn't there an advantage to being a lady
fighter because you don't have like a
huge firm a weak spot for me oh you've
obviously never been punched in the
titties how come you can't have it like
low blow yeah mid blow I'd rather not
have to think about it i throw body
shots all the time and i hate to have to
be you know never just careful the boob
zone
I know how it feels bit like she's like
like Mortal Kombat wavering and you got
if it be that sounded meant I probably
would do it a lot more often you find
the right girl it will so let's share
some tough things we've both done in our
lives
you can go first um I beat up a bunch
guys in a movie theater once holy [ __ ]
what's your tough thing I like to make
my own shampoo what about sex before a
fight cuz I've heard the boxers don't do
that because they lose their life energy
are you just trying to get me to say
this cuz I think you know my answer
already
you like having text before a match
that's a guess I didn't know well it's
uh it's actually a proven medical fact
that testosterone is raised in women
after they have sex so you do have sex
before your fight I mean I'm not gonna
walk around the hotel with my shirt off
and try and find somebody that's too bad
killin time able able-bodied able-bodied
seamen nice to know that you're not in
the band no low demand available you
could text me a question mark and I'd be
there real fast I thought it would be
fun to get in the ring and you could
show me some moves I'm pretty athletic
Carlos
I heard something crag I did too
okay I'm not athletic as you can see I
was sweating just from the interview
sometimes I get AR - mm-hmm don't hit me
in the boobs
don't grab it I can see you looking at
me like The Terminator robot and you
know all these things to do thinking
about oh my god good okay you're gonna
throw me yeah really why not run this
yeah are on the way see you again cuz
you right now isn't so bad right I'm
getting wet now okay yeah we're getting
cozy for the night notice I have to make
sure my feet are right between your feet
and then I get hip to hip here I think
should my hips lower in yours Oh God in
heaven okay let's do it for real now see
that that's what real men you can you do
that I got wide hips for a dude show me
how to throw you I just stand up and
look to your left
what stand up stand up not fall down on
your knees on the ground oh yeah the
opposite of condescending you know I am
so sorry what's your signature move arm
bar arm bar and you know it's called it
GG Khatami I'm on your arm uh-huh I like
it's go over yeah
I said you forgot to talk about your
calf in my face most people probably
don't complain about the calf to the
face but it was more painful than I
thought it would be my mom that you got
all your makeup off of my Luna
I'm not wearing makeup I'm a dude I
won't break it off don't worry I'm okay
yeah I need it for scooping ice cream
hug you lean back right huh
yeah you feel it already I do Phyllis I
urge my hips no start to hurt yes
how'd you learn this my mom taught it to
me yeah mom my mom taught me songs and
Lithuanian that's awesome yeah that
wasn't part of my chubby last gnash
alive us punished man yell it wah shits
real this is my signature move thank you
so much Radha I really forgot some basic
knowledge today and will never be the
same